Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich wie
immer am selben Ort
Richard gutes Fernsehen ja ein schönes
Zitat am Anfang gutes Fernsehen ist
eines das mich fordert und alles das
mich nicht unterfordert dein
Lieblingsautor
Willemsen genau
und ich finde das großartig aber wenn
man so intelligent ist wie Robert
Willemsen dann ist man nicht die
klassische Zielgruppe des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks weil
dann schreiten 99% aller anderen unter
dieser zielmarsche einher
möglicherweise bin mir da gar nicht
sicher ich habe eine andere Theorie aber
darüber sollten wir heute mal reden ich
ich freue mich total dass wir heute ist
ein bisschen schwieriger eine eine
Gradwanderung weil ich selber da nicht
ganz unbefangen bin
wir feiern ein schönes Jubiläum seit 60
Jahren seit dem ersten April
1963 gibt es das Zweite Deutsche
Fernsehen das ZDF also es gibt schon so
lange wie das ZDF wie Kennedy Tote ist
so ungefähr dass du jetzt jetzt
gleich in die Gruft steigst das ist
jetzt natürlich irgendwie Vorstellungen
in welcher Zeit das war ja ich denke ja
ganz andere Dinge die 60er aber wie
schmecken die 60er für dich so mein
gefühltes Lieblings Jahrzehnt ja also
ich bin in den 60ern geboren anders als
du ne und ich bin Ende der 60er also ich
habe sozusagen noch so so so nostalgisch
kuschelige Gefühle an meine früher
Kindheit also ich bin ja im Dezember 64
geboren aber so noch fünf Jahre lang die
60er mitgekriegt
und habe diesen Kulturwandel von den
60ern zu den 70ern der fällt halt
zusammen von meiner kleinen Kind Zeit in
meine Kinderzeit und Fernsehen spielte
da eine Rolle bei uns ne wir hatten kein
Fernseher
finanziellen Gründen sondern weil für
meine linken Eltern das Fernsehen ein
verdummungsmedium war und sonst nichts
und das zweite war und das ist der
erheblich bessere Teil an der Sache
alle Zeit die Kinder damit verbringen
Fernsehen zu gucken verbringen sie nicht
mit anderen Sachen also nicht mit
Spielen der körperlichen Ertüchtigung
nicht mit Lesen nicht mit Malen und so
weiter und das ist natürlich auch völlig
richtig
und deswegen wurde das Fernsehen von uns
soweit das möglich war ferngehalten es
war aber in zwei Punkten nicht möglich
unter uns wohnte eine nette Familie mit
drei Kindern Christians und die hatten
noch die hatten einen Fernseher und dann
wurden wir schon mal ausgeklingelt zum
Fernsehen gucken und das durften wir
schon mal und das war noch so ein
Fernseher da war noch vor vorher der
wurde erstmal aufgeschlossen und da
wurde rechts und links die Tür
aufgemacht und hölzern Vorhang das war
so ein richtiges Ritual so wie im Kino
Leinwand ja also alles natürlich noch
eine Welt in schwarz-weiß und da habe
ich dann die ein oder andere Kinderserie
geguckt wobei meine Eltern großen Wert
darauf dass wir keine amerikanischen
Kinderserien gucken weil der
Klassenfeind naja es war die Zeit des
Vietnamkrieges das war die Zeit des
Vietnamkrieges und dieser ganze
Streichelzoo der da in die deutschen
Wohnzimmer kam weil die lässt dies und
Furries und skippies
und so weiter das war halt die gleiche
Nation die da in Vietnam die
bauerndorfer und die Kinder und so
weiter umbrachte das war für für meine
Eltern gegen das nicht aber es gab ja
deutsche Fernsehproduktion und da habe
ich die eine oder andere von gesehen
nämlich was hast du gesagt der die
Konkurrenz zu loben in der ARD liefen
zwei Dinge die ich letztens mal so bei
einem Abend erzählt habe und alle
Gleichaltrigen behaupteten dass ein
Erfindungen von mir oder ich hätte als
Kind DDR Fernsehen geguckt weil sich
überhaupt niemand daran erinnert konnte
und das andere war Wolfgang und Stoffe
ja das war ein so ein ein netter Herr
der hatte eine kleine Pappschachtel im
Regal und da drin wohnte ein kleines
Wesen namens Stoffel
und was ich sehr geliebt habe war Kasper
und Rene und daran konnte sie überhaupt
nie jemand erinnern jemals davon gehört
zu haben und das war so eine majonette
und ein Schauspieler und
da ging es so in die Märchenwelt rein
nur da musste man auch raten so Märchen
und Märchen Schauplätze raten und so das
war nicht so interaktives Fernsehen ja
ja genau interaktives Fernsehen das
Spiel 60er also genau meine frühen
Fernseher Erinnerung und natürlich als
wir einen Fernseher bekam wie kriegten
dann einen Fernseher ein
schwarz-weiß-fernseher als das
Farbfernsehen kam damit war quasi der
Abstand zum verdummungsmedium ja
gewartet ja also die hinten dem
technischen Fortschritt signifikant
hinterher hatten jetzt aber im Fernseher
und da durften wir Dick und Doof gucken
ach herrlich oder Väter der Klamotte
wobei Väter der Klamotte hatte ein Haken
nach Väter der Klamotte kam Männer ohne
Nerven
und dazwischen war Werbung und zwar
natürlich besonders auf Kinder abzielen
eine Werbung klar ne also für
Kinderschokolade und sowas so wir
durften natürlich um nichts in der Welt
Werbung gucken also ging meine Mutter ja
in dem Moment wo Väter der Klamotte
ausmacht zum Fernseher dreht sie den
Knopf ab so und jetzt war es so dass der
Knopf erst wieder angedreht wurde wenn
man ganz ganz sicher sein konnte dass
keine Werbung mehr lief auf die Art und
Weise habe ich den Anfang von Männer
ohne Nerven immer verpasst und ihr
himmelten hin und her und wollten Männer
ohne Nerven sehen und sind dann einmal
unsreise zum Fernsehen zu gehen dann
lief da noch Werbung so Strafe durften
wir Männer ohne Schokolade spielen
weil wir ja Konsum und Reklame geile
waren wie meine Mutter das ausdrückte
das sind meine frühen Fernseher
Erlebnisse wir haben immer also Charlie
Chaplin hat mich immer beeindruckt und
dieser dieser Gang von Charlie Chaplin
und wir haben auch viele sehr junge
Menschen die uns zuhören und die kennen
auch alle Charlie Chaplin das ist
einfach zeitlos gut mich hat neulich
etwas sehr berührt ich habe Jim Carrey
gesehen den ich über alle Maßen mag und
ich höre mir oft Interviews mit Jim
Carrey an weil er immer so kluge Sachen
sagt und da hatte er erzählt über
Charlie Chaplin und sagte die Geschichte
von Charlie Chaplin habe ihn so bewegt
so berührt weil der ihn bitte bitte
armen Verhältnissen aufgewachsen ist und
hat sich dann sozusagen da einfach
langsam hochgearbeitet und sich seine
eigene Welt erschaffen und hat sich in
dieser Welt dann einfach vollkommen
verloren und zeitlose wunderschöne Kunst
geschaffen und sagte dieser typische
Charlie Chaplin Gang kam unter anderem
dadurch zustande dass der kein Geld für
adäquat große Schuhe hatte kein Geld
eine neue Schuhe der ist immer so
gelaufen dass er sozusagen maximal
schuhschonend unterwegs war und deswegen
dieser dieser weltberühmte Gang dieser
Charlie Chaplin Gang den wir alle so
kennen und man denkt dass ist ein Gag
das war aber kein Gag sondern das war
schlicht eine Überlebensnotwendigkeit
mich irgendwie sehr berührt und wir
haben wir haben immer auf dem Weg zum
Milch holen haben wir uns immer
sozusagen so ein bisschen so ein
bisschen Fernsehen ergaunert wir mussten
immer abends so gegen sechs Milch holen
da war die Kuh dann fertig gemolken beim
Nachbarn und wir hatten ja keinen
Fernseher zu Hause wir wussten aber so
gegen 18 Uhr und auch ein bisschen
schnell kommt dann Trio mit vier Fäusten
und solche Dinge die haben wir dann
immer geguckt und das waren sowohl so
meine Helden ja und waren dann immer
sehr sehr pünktlich beim Milch holen und
haben auch gesagt sie soll sich ein
bisschen Zeit lassen mit dem mit dem
Melken damit wir in Ruhe Trio mit wir
Fäusten oder auch ein Gold für alle
Fälle und solche Sachen zu Ende gucken
konnten und das interessante bei uns ich
komme aus einem einem kleinen Tal und
dort gab es nur das ZDF also die ARD war
ja schon längst in Deutschland da und
bei uns aber war die ARD nicht zu sehen
das ZDF kam 1975 nach Südtirol ist seit
93 erst im Kabelfernsehen vertreten aber
ich kenne sozusagen in meiner Kindheit
gab es nur das ZDF italienisches
Fernsehen noch bestimmt oder
italienisches Fernsehen gab es auch aber
das hatte das war immer sehr verschneit
da gab es noch keine Satelliten und so
weiter und auf jedem Hügel auf jedem
Berg musste dann so eine Antenne stehen
und wir wir gucken da lieber deutsches
Fernsehen das war für uns großartig dass
der Grund warum das ZDF in Südtirol so
populär war und einer der Gründe warum
ich mich irgendwie zum ZDF immer so
magisch hingezogen fühlte vielleicht
Stockholm Syndrom ja das war war in
meiner Kindheit gab es nur gab es nur
das ZDF die ARD hat für mich da gar
nicht existiert
für mich ist das ZDF ja der Weg ja die
die toten Augen aus München direkt das
Personal
ja wirklich für das das war doch so eine
ganz neue Form von Krimi die da
plötzlich um die Ecke kam hast du der
geguckt
selten und schon als Jugendlicher
langweilig gefunden
weil ich glaube Derrick und das war ja
ein Welterfolg ne es gibt ja glaube ich
in jeder Sprache der Welt gibt es direkt
ja also das Geheimnis hinter Derrick
besteht darin einen Krimi zu machen ja
der nicht verängstigt sondern beruhigt
es war nie spannend im Beruhigungsmittel
nein Quatsch die Italiener haben Derrick
geliebte lisbetore der Regio ja die
Italiener kennen den alle ja die
deutsche Spießigkeit so wunderbar
verkauft hat die anderen Ländern zu
ihrem Leidwesen fehlen
deswegen war der glaube ich der
allergrößte Erfolg meine ich mal gehört
haben hätte das in Japan gehabt
also das kann ein Italien auch
derrickweise glaube ich ein Problem
emotionaler Kommentar aber völlig nach
dem Geschmack der Japaner aber ich werde
nie verstehen warum das in Deutschland
so lange so erfolgreich war ich glaube
es ist so dieses Gefühl es war
grauenvoll ich freue mich auf die
nächste Folge es gab wahrscheinlich eine
Zeit so 60er 70er Jahre wo Männer mit
Hornbrillen besonders vertrauenserwecken
waren ja also das ist so nach dem Motto
welches Schweine hätten es denn gern ja
das mit dem Brille ja und dann eben
diese direkt Brille na also heute Kult
Gegenstände eben also solche Brillen
ganz großer Zeit weit voraus Derrick war
seiner Zeit weit voraus und so lustig in
dem Zusammenhang nicht Harald Schmidt
wurde dann doch später berühmt mit dem
Satz Harry fahr schon mal den Wagen vor
der Satz ist nie gefehlt kann gar nicht
fallen weil weil es gibt eine ganz klare
Erklärung warum der Satz nicht fällt
weil du nie siehst dass die irgendwo in
Autos ein und aussteigen sondern das
Prinzip ist dass drin sitzen das ist
Sendung ist ganz statisch das ist so
ähnlich wie bei Dallas und bei Denver du
siehst also wie Pamela Ewing in ihrem
wunderbaren Mercedes Cabrio ja von der
southforg Ranch fährt du siehst aber
nicht dass sie irgendwohin fährt sondern
die nächste Station ist dass sie dann
vorm old Barons Club ist oder im
allmerlands Club das heißt man hat also
sendungsökonomisch immer die
Verbindungswege rausgekürzt weil den
Drehbuchautoren dafür nichts eingefallen
ist und das war bei direkt genau
dasselbe also die Sendung ist so
holzschnittartig dass solche Szenen
nicht vorgesehen waren also Derrick war
Psychologie ja
was hast du psychologisches aus Derrick
gelernt na alles irgendwie das ganze
Elend dieser Welt diese diese deutsche
Melancholie dieser Welt oder das Elend
in München
das war für mich auch gleichzeitig weißt
du ich saß in Südtirol hinter den Bergen
bei den sieben Zwergen und wir haben das
geguckt und hattest Angst vor Münchner
Willen Vororten weil die voller Mörder
sind naja also Menschen saßen auch
häufig im Rollstuhl und wurden dann
gemorcht oder oder der Typ der Mörder
war der im Rollstuhl das war ja immer so
die große Frage was wurden sehr viele
Mörder noch Rollstuhlfahrer sein dürfen
im indirekt tauchten das ist gehört für
mich so zu den Bildern von der Erik und
wieder waren immer sehr viele Menschen
im Rollstuhl unterwegs und diese weißt
du diese diese diese diese
emotionslose dieser emotionslose Vortrag
von von Horst Tappert ja wenn er Derrick
spielte hat mich dann auch immer
erinnert da gab es für mich die direkte
Verbindung erinnerst du dich an Konrads
Aktenzeichen
nee das war das war
genau
mit seiner Tochter Sabine darüber
gesprochen der saß glaube ich selber
sogar in meinem Gefängnis ja ja genau
richtig der der dann später Aktenzeichen
Nepper Schlepper bauanfänger ich glaube
das war eher seine Wiege okay
es immer Konrad dünns aus aus Bern der
war dann zugeschaltet und hat auch immer
mit auch mit so einer Hornbrille
übernommen okay so so tonlos vorgetragen
das in der Schweiz wieder irgendein
Emmentaler Käse verschwunden ist oder so
das war das war mal unheimlich wichtig
gruselt darf ich mochte das und das war
für mich Psychologie es war so
Kammerspiel weißt du Psychologie wie die
zwölf geschworenenheit in München du
hast mich deine lieblings ja okay also
was ist das beste was ist eine in
diesbezüglich im deutschen Fernsehen je
gegeben hat war Zoll fahrender Christin
den hast du nicht mehr erlebt mit einem
meiner ultimativen Lieblingsschauspieler
Sieg hat Rupp okay Österreicher
Sieghart Rupp den älteren noch bekannt
als Schurke in Karl-May-Filme
ja der spielt den Bösen in unter Geiern
ein sehr gut aussehender Mann aber das
Beste an sie hat Rupp war nicht nur dass
er unverschämt gut aussah sondern dass
er eine unglaublich metallische Stimme
hatte cool eine ganz große tolle Stimme
und dieser auf das Böse Fach
spezialisierte Sieg hat Rupp spielte in
einigen Folgen es war kein großer Erfolg
wir haben schnell wieder abgesetzt soll
fahrender Christin und die hat ging
dermaßen offensiv mit Frauen um Anfang
der 70er Jahre das wäre auch heute noch
würde man sagen
mein erster einmal Spruch ja den ich
benutzt habe habe ich natürlich von sie
gerade Rupp ja und das ist wenn man das
in einer Galerie reinkommt eine Frau
Teufel findet ja sie anlächelt und zu
ihr sagt wir haben uns aber noch nie
gesehen und das fand ich damals immer
wenn du unglaublich gut und ich habe das
auch in meinem Leben das ein oder andere
Mal praktiziert
war auch nicht das Schlimmste was man
sagen konnte
großartig Monaco Franze ist das einzige
was ich bedauere dass das nicht im ZDF
ist großes Kino oder finde ich auch also
Monaco Franze obwohl viel gelobt immer
noch unterschätzt aber Richard
öffentlich rechtliches Fernsehen ich ähm
wenn man mein Ziel und jetzt kommen weg
von schönen Kindheitserinnerungen ich
habe schon das Gefühl dass da gerade was
passiert da gibt es richtige Fronten die
sich da aufgebaut haben diese Fronten
werden zum Teil auch medial gefüttert da
gibt's z.B den Springer Verlag der wie
wie Stefanie Mayas vor einiger Zeit im
ausgedruckt hat dann eine rasende Wut
gegen dieses öffentlich rechtliche
System hat ähm gibt Leute die mit der
größten Selbstverständlichkeit
mittlerweile von vom vom vom
Zwangsgebühren sprechen und so weiter
und voller Verachtung auf System gucken
und die Frage ist was wäre besser
Richard wenn es kein
öffentlich-rechtliches Fernsehen gebe
also grundsätzlich nicht
also ich denke mal das viele Länder in
der Welt und um öffentlich rechtliches
Fernsehen beneiden
und dass man was die Stabilität der
Demokratie anbelangt sagen muss dass das
öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen da ein
ganz wichtiges Bindeglied und das Länder
die sowas nicht haben wie die USA zum
Beispiel auch deutlich instabiler sind
natürlich nicht alleine deswegen aber
ich glaube schon dass das
öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen für die
demokratische Verständigung eine große
Rolle gespielt hat und auch nach wie vor
spielt und das ist Medien gibt die nicht
in privater Hand sind
ist ein großes Glück dass wir haben es
ist gut ein öffentlich-rechtliches
Fernsehen zu haben oder ein
öffentlich-rechtlichen rundfunkeln ja
auch die Radio Programme zu das heißt
die die medienetikerin Johanna Haberer
die irgendwann sagte wir haben einen
Rundfunksystem nach dem Krieg geschenkt
bekommen dass darauf angelegt war
demokratische Strukturen abzubilden die
hat recht ja sie hat auf jeden Fall aber
aber dieses Bewusstsein dafür ist uns
irgendwie abhanden gekommen und lass uns
einfach alle Dinge also erstmal ganz
grundsätzlich alle Dinge die völlig
selbstverständlich sind so und und jeder
der uns zuhört ist selbstverständlich
mit dem Wissen dass es ein
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk gibt
aufgewachsen oder fast jeder jedenfalls
wenn das so selbstverständlich ist dann
denkt man über die Vorteile selten und
über die Nachteile eher nach also
Nachteile eben Sinne von ja wieso muss
ich hier Rundfunkgebühren zahlen auch
wenn ich das nicht gucke
oder eben dass man bestimmte Dinge
inhaltlich nicht gut findet und dafür
den öffentlichen rechtlichen Rundfunk
als Ganzes verantwortlich macht und das
halte ich für ein Fehler also ich habe
ja auch ein Buch was ich mit Harald
Welzer geschrieben habe das eine oder
andere am öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk kritisiert aber es ist auch ein
Unterschied ob man als grundsätzlicher
Liebhaber etwas kritisiert weil man
denkt das geht besser oder ob man das
System für falsch hält das ist ein
riesiger Unterschied
und ich denke einfach vielen ist der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk so
selbstverständlich dass Sie die Vorteile
auch nicht mehr sehen die Kritik ist ja
wirklich massiv also die die Kritik vor
allen Dingen aus der privaten
Verlagswirtschaft und man hat da
wirklich das Gefühl da wird da wird so
eine echte Front aufgebaut und
interessant ist wenn man mit Leuten z.B
vom Spiegel ich eine mich an will jetzt
keine Namen nennen aber eine namhafte
Kollegin vom Spiegel mit der ich vor
einiger Zeit nach einer Sendung darüber
gesprochen habe und sagte wie siehst du
das was passiert da gerade und warum
arbeitet ihr euch ständig aus dem
öffentlich-rechtlichen System ab sagte
naja gut das hat unter anderem damit zu
tun dass wir in einer sehr sehr harten
Konkurrenzsituation sind und das das
verstehe ich auch das sehe ich auch die
Verlage kämpfen zum Teil wirklich ums
Überleben auf der anderen Seite sagte
sie wenn du in die USA guckst und jemand
der auch lange in den USA gearbeitet hat
sie wagte die These jemand wie Trump
wäre möglicherweise nicht 2016 gewählt
worden wenn es ein starkes
öffentlich-rechtliches
Fernsehen oder oder Rundfunksystem würde
und das ist ja die Idee dahinter
sorgfältige journalistische Arbeit zu
leisten Dinge zu überprüfen
Informationen auf ihren Wahrheitswert
abzuklopfen und so weiter sind ja
genuine Aufgaben des öffentlich
rechtlichen Fernsehens ich würde
natürlich auch sagen dem wird mal mehr
nachgekommen und mal weniger da gibt's
auch einiges zu kritisieren aber das
überhaupt so etwas da ist
also wenn überhaupt nichts da ist was
diese Qualitätsansprüche erfüllen muss
ne und die Bild-Zeitung muss sie nicht
erfüllen und Fox News muss sie nicht
erfüllen und so weiter wenn es das also
gar nicht mehr gibt wenn es gar nicht
mehr vorgesehen ist dann reißt das
gegenüber dem was wir heute haben mit
Sicherheit eine Lücke deswegen kann ich
ja den Satz nur wiederholen von vorhin
das ist ein öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk gibt der quasi dessen
Verfassungsauftrag darin besteht zu
objektiv wie möglich zu informieren die
liberativ zu sein das heißt also
wirklich viele Menschen
zu beteiligen einen Prozessen integrativ
zu sein für die Gesellschaft und
inklusiv zu sein im Hinblick auf
unterschiedliche Interessengruppen und
Meinungen es ist ein von der Sache her
etwas Großartiges ich würde sagen wenn
wir keine öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk haben dann sollten wir ihn
erfinden ja man könnte sogar sagen warum
haben eigentlich so wenige Länder das ja
wäre das nicht toll wenn andere Länder
das auch hätten also das Prinzip
öffentlich rechtlicher Rundfunk
überzeugt mich völlig was im
Umkehrschluss nicht heißt dass alles das
was der öffentliche rechtliche Rundfunk
macht und jeder einzelne Journalist und
jeder einzelne Sendung zu jedem
Zeitpunkt von mir gut geheißen wird das
sind zwei verschiedene Dinge es sind
zwei verschiedene Dinge und lass uns
darüber auch mal reden ich meine wenn
man das sich so anschaut in ganz Europa
kommen genau dieses System unter Druck
das ganz interessant wenn man mal eine
andere Länder schaut also die die
Österreicher haben so etwas ja das
da liegt die Rundfunkgebühr glaube ich
bei 2021 Euro der öffentlich-rechtlich
Rundfunk der ORF kriegt davon glaube ich
ungefähr 17
das heißt die sind ungefähr so hoch wie
wir wir sind ja bei 18,36 € in
Frankreich wird darüber diskutiert in in
England Boris Johnson eines der
Lieblings hassobjekte von Boris Johnson
doch keine Interviews gegeben war
ausgerechnet die gute alte BBC äh in in
Italien gibt es die Diskussion die
gibt's dann ganz viele Kontinent und man
hat das Gefühl da da kommt gerade ein
ein System rechts sozusagen um von von
Populisten genutzt zu werden um auch da
wieder sozusagen die die Wut der Leute
auf irgendetwas was dann Zwangsgebühr
genannt wird
zu steigern
ich fand es interessant diese ganze
Debatte um den Rundfunkbeitrag hast du
das verfolgt damals Richard aber ich
habe 86 Cent die ein irrsinniges
verhätzungspotenzial plötzlich hatten
man hatte plötzlich das Gefühl 86 Cent
daran entscheidet sich jetzt sozusagen
der Wohlstand eines ganzen Landes
gleichzeitig haben Leute Netflix Abos
haben Abos bei Disney und so weiter weil
sie sagen dass das haben wir uns mal die
freiwillig Hunde als Kunde ja und das
verstehe ich bin nicht aussuchen kann
das macht natürlich einen Unterschied
erstmal nee das verstehe ich ich fand es
nur trotzdem interessant weil um diese
86 Cent ist eine zum Teil völlig außer
Kontrolle geraten auch politisch
populistisch genutzte Debatte entstanden
86 Cent diese 86 Cent wurden unglaublich
geistelt und möglicherweise auch zurecht
das kann man alles kritisieren weil auch
86 Cent ist Geld und 18,36 € insgesamt
ist noch mal deutlich mehr was aber in
der Debatte so gut wie immer unter den
Tisch gefallen ist und das finde ich an
dem Punkt einfach nicht in Ordnung wenn
man versucht das ganze Bild zu malen
2015 im April 2015 sind die
Rundfunkgebühren gesunken von 1798 auf
17 Euro 50 und zwar das erste Mal in der
Geschichte des rundfunkbeitrags das
passierte durch die Umstellung von der
gerätebezogenen Gebühr auf den
Rundfunkbeitrag im Jahre 2013 und ich
finde wenn man diese harte Debatte so
führt und speziell der der Springer
Verlag führt sie extrem hart dann finde
ich dann sollte man doch so fair sein
und zumindest das mit in seine
Überlegungen mit einbeziehen und das mit
in die Diskussion werfen das ist einfach
nicht in Ordnung das einfach immer
wegzulassen nämlich den Fakt dass vor
einigen Jahren 20 15 die Gebühren sogar
gesunken sind aber sag mal wie stark
schätzt du denn das eigentlich ein also
ich war unlängst an der Evangelischen
Akademie in Tutzing und hatte da eine
Podiumsdiskussion und vor mir war Peter
frei der langjährige Politik Chef beim
ZDF
redakte und der sah ähm tatsächlich
seine ernst zu nehmen Bedrohung im
Rechtspopulismus mit dessen Forderung
eben entweder den öffentlich rechtlichen
Rundfunk zu übernehmen und das wird in
Deutschland nicht funktionieren und als
Alternative ihn eben abzuschaffen
siehst du eine ernstzunehmende Gefahr in
Deutschland dass das passieren
naja also wenn du wenn du zum Beispiel
liest das glaubten 30 Prozent ungefähr
der Deutschen sind dafür dass dieses
System mit den zwei großen
senderanstalten oder den zwei großen
Sendern dass das so erhalten bleiben
soll ungefähr 30 Prozent dann kann ich
mir ausrechnen dass ungefähr 70 Prozent
das anders sehen ja aber da geht es um
die beiden also ein großer Unterschied
sagen wir mal zwei Drittel der der Leute
in Deutschland sagen warum kann man ARD
und ZDF nicht zusammenlegen und dann
wird es günstiger oder ob man sagt ich
nehme den öffentlich rechtlichen
Rundfunk ab und grundsätzlich jegliche
Form von Gebühren das sind ja nur zwei
ganz verschiedene Aussagen ja es war
aber ich ich habe schon das Gefühl in
Zeiten in den so viel
unwidersprochen noch auf in den sozialen
Netzwerken einfach behauptet werden kann
und mit welcher Selbstverständlichkeit
sich dieses Wort Zwangsgebühren einfach
so durchgesetzt hat und da reden wir
jetzt speziell auch lass uns mal raus
und Reiter nennen über
Springerverlag ja mit welcher mit
welchem
Eifer mit welchem ja wie geil fand zum
Teil jeder noch so kleine Fehler
in der Tagesschau beim ZDF egal wo
irgendwo man falsches Logo ein
weiß ich nicht an falsches Bild gezeigt
etwas wo du merkst okay da arbeiten
Menschen und da passiert auch meinen
Fehler ich rede nicht von den von den
richtig großen Dingen die man dann
zurecht kritisiert bei jeder kleinste
Kleinigkeit wird zur ultimativen
Peinlichkeit hochgejtzt und so weiter
und ich habe mir noch mal angesehen was
damals Georg Altrogge der
diesbezüglich sehr viel kommentiert und
der für Bild gerade Medien Journalismus
kritisiert wie der losgelegt hat als es
um diese 86 Cent ging deswegen reite ich
da auch so drauf rum Kommentar zum
rundfunkbeschluss Überschrift dieser
Kniefall gefährdet die Demokratie und
dann schreibt er dieser heutige
Beschluss des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
zur Gebührenordnung und so weiter es
mehr als ein Skandal es gefährdet die
Grundfesten der föderalen Demokratie
jetzt pass auf den frei gewählten
Abgeordneten der Landesparlamente ist
nämlich nur noch erlaubt ja zu sagen
wenn die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen mehr
Geld verlangen ein Nein ist ab sofort
verfassungswidrig und
Stefan Niggemeier mit dem ich oft über
Kreuz liege und so weiter dann sehr
klugen guten Kommentar dazu geschrieben
er sagte nämlich das verkürzt diesen
Prozess der Beitragsfestsetzung
mutwillig um ganz entscheidende Schritte
und sagt die Abgeordneten Stimme nämlich
nicht über das ab was die öffentlich
rechtlichen fordern sondern sie stimmen
über das ab was die Ministerpräsidenten
der Länder gemeinsam beschlossen haben
und dieser Beschluss der
Ministerpräsidenten basiert auf dem was
eine unabhängige Kommission zur
Ermittlung Finanzbedarfs ist die KEV ja
Kommission zu Ermittlung des
Finanzbedarfs des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks was die vorschlagen und deren
Vorschlag basiert also auf der
Überprüfung der Forderung von ARD und
ZDF und in der Regel wird Demi
stattgegeben in der Regel kommt die KEV
hin und sagt okay ihr wollt mehr Geld
geben wir euch aber nicht ihr wollt ein
Euro mehr wollt zwei Euro mehr ich
kriege aber nur 80 Cent als Beispiel das
ist das worüber dann abgestimmt wird
über eine unabhängige Kommission zur
Ermittlung des Finanzbedarfs darüber
reden wir wir reden nicht darüber dass
sozusagen ein öffentlich-rechtlicher
Intendant einfach hingehen kann und
sagen kann bitteschön wir hätten gerne 2
€ mehr und jetzt stimmt die gefälligst
mal ab und wenn die das nicht macht in
unserem Sinne abstimmt dann gehen wir
zum Bundesverfassungsgericht und dann
machen die das und dann wird es in
unserem Sinne einfach so entschieden so
ist das nicht und ich finde das wichtig
dass man klar zu machen da sind viele
viele Schritte immer wieder dazwischen
wenn es darum geht wie hoch sollen diese
Gebühren sein auch deswegen weil man
natürlich genau das nicht möchte diese
Staatsnähe man möchte nicht dass
Parteien Parlamente über unmittelbar
Einfluss nehmen können auf einen
unabhängigen öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk das ist auch das Argument
sozusagen
dagegen einen öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk einfach so aus Steuermitteln zu
finanzieren man könnte ja sagen wir
schaffen diese Gebühr einfach ab und
wird das einfach aus Steuern bezahlt aus
dem Bundeshaushalt einfach bezahlt aber
dann wäre das ist immer das Argument der
Grünen z.B und auch andere die sagen das
würde dann dazu führen dass es eine viel
viel größere Nähe gebe und dann könnten
wir sehr viel mehr Einfluss nehmen auf
das was da berichtet wird und du kannst
sie nicht vorstellen dieses dieses
Gefühl als Regierung die Steuermittel
drastische Höhen oder man könnte sie
daran dramatisch reduzieren das heißt
man hätte also ein absolutes
rettungspotenzial gegenüber dem
öffentlich rechtlichen Prüfung genau das
meine ich und dieses Gefühl sozusagen
entstehen zu lassen
da da gibt es so ein paar durchgeknallte
beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen
und die sagen einfach an und dann legen
Sie das den Landesparlamenten vor und
die müssen wir einfach abnicken ob ihnen
das gefällt oder nicht anders
würde ich nicht sagen und ich meine die
Leute beschäftigen sich nicht intensiv
damit das beste die Leute den Leuten ist
das nicht klar und deswegen ist das
wichtig dass man zu verstehen diese
verschiedenen Schritte und was da alles
getan wird sozusagen um diese Staatsnähe
eben gerade nicht zu haben und ich will
das auch mal ausdrücklich weil wir heute
darüber reden sagen du kannst sie nicht
vorstellen wie oft ich darauf
angesprochen werde von Menschen die mir
sagen
müssen Sie bestimmte Leute einladen wer
schreibt den eigentlich die Themen vor
wie müssen sie über bestimmte Dinge
reden oder berichten und ich sag dann
immer ich muss gar nichts sondern ich
rede so wie ich denke dass man wenn man
sich mit den Argumenten beschäftigt hat
reden muss und niemand schreibt mir vor
wie ich irgend jemanden zu befragen habe
niemand schreibt mir vor was ich nicht
zu tun habe wenn jemand schreibt mir vor
was ich zu tun habe
indirekte indirekte Form von
Vorschriften zum Beispiel könntest du
nicht deine Sendung machen und
ausnahmslos immer nur Männer einladen
also es gibt es gibt schon aber das ist
ja auf ja aber gesellschaftlicher
Inhalten genau es geht genau es geht ja
darum dass wenn man die Gesellschaft
abbilden möchte und wenn man sich quasi
auf der Höhe der Gesellschaft bewegen
möchte dann folgende heraus
Selbstverpflichtungen ja richtig auch
halten das wäre aber was anderes als als
der Anruf an der Chefredakteurs der dir
sagt pass auf den bitte ja und die bitte
nicht das findet nicht stattfindet
einfach nicht stand also mir hat Peter
frei gesagt oder dem Publikum hatte er
gesagt es gibt schon Gäste die man in
Talkshows nicht mehr einlädt z.B zum
Beispiel Björn höcke ja das könnte man
es gebe zwei Gründe wie man das
rechtfertigen kann er hat das jetzt
nicht so ausführlich gerechtfertigt aber
wir würden zwei einfallen
also das eine ist warum sollte ich
gestern einladen die nicht auf dem Boden
der freiheitlich demokratischen
Grundordnung stehen und die ein
Gedankengut von sich geben dass nicht
unserem Werte kann und entsprechend und
quasi auch nicht unseren
verfassungsmäßigen Grundsätzen
dass deine Grenze ist das kann ich
nachvollziehen
genau und der zweite Grenze ist niemand
einzuladen von dem man weiß dass er lügt
also wenn das jemand sozusagen komplett
alternative Fakten verbreitet wo absolut
klar und erwiesen ist mein
wissenschaftlich nachprüfen kann das ist
totaler Unsinn dann muss man ihn auch
nicht einladen also das wären zwei
Grenzen
ja es riecht würdest du sagen dass ihr
die in der Talkshow nicht habt würdest
du jemanden einladen der behauptet es
gebe keinen menschengemachte Klimawandel
das würde ich mir im Einzelfall immer
angucken ich
finde immer man muss grundsätzlich
erstmal versuchen mit einem Gespräch zu
sein das Thema ist ja immer zum Beispiel
die AFD und ich glaube tatsächlich wenn
wir jetzt über über Kritik reden ich
glaube wir müssten uns der AFD häufiger
stellen bzw wir müssten versuchen AFD
Abgeordnete häufiger in Sendungen zu
haben und zu stellen da bin ich auf
deiner Seite und ich habe das auch schon
oft gesagt auf einen öffentlichen
Diskussionen dass ich den Umgang des
öffentlichen rechtlichen Rundfunks mit
der AFD für falsch halte und für uns
sowas reden sonst war es folgendem Grund
als die AFD plötzlich stark war eine
Partei mit über 5 %. da wurden ihre
Vorsitzenden ich erinnere mich dann sich
Fach an Frauke Petri in Talkshows
eingeladen und dann wurden vier Leute
dagegen eingeladen und dann kam ein
Spieler und das war immer und immer
wieder in den irgendwelche Parteifreunde
von Frauke Petry sich in irgendeiner
Menschen verachtend oder im nazi-jargon
geäußert haben und ihre Aufgabe bestand
dann darin während der Talkshow immer
darauf hinzuweisen dass das keine
Nazi-Partei ist
das führt natürlich zu gar nichts man
weiß gar nicht was will die AFD
eigentlich wie entwickelt die sich wir
wissen dass die AFD nicht nur Fan Nazis
gewählt wird das wissen auch die Leute
die dann die Talkshow machen richtig
warum hat man mit Frauke Petry nicht
darüber geredet wie sie sich ein
zukünftiges Deutschland oder Europa
vorstellt warum hat man nicht
Entzauberung dadurch dass man erzählt
was man will Betrieben ja ich habe
später mein Video Podcast mit Frauke
Petry gemacht einfach weil mich das
interessiert hat ne und das interessante
sie war so darauf konditioniert immer zu
sagen was sie nicht will richtig dass
sie eigentlich nie gesagt hat was was
will genau jetzt weiß ich nicht ob das
immer schon war oder ob das ein Reflex
ist wenn man tausendmal von den Medien
ja immer in irgendeine Ecke gestellt
wird und man sich immer rechtfertigen
muss dass man sagt in diese Ecke gehört
man so nicht rein aber es wäre doch viel
souveräner im Umgang gewesen die die AFD
ihre positiven Visionen für Deutschland
erzählen zu lassen um dann natürlich im
Zweifelsfall dabei rauszufinden
positiv sind oder nicht realistisch aber
dass sie doch zumindestens dargestellt
werden und nicht jemand immer nur damit
beschäftigt ist sagen zu müssen was er
nicht ist
ich finde das hätte man besser machen
können und das finde ich auch ich glaube
dass man die AFD sogar unter anderem
stark gemacht hat dadurch und dass man
auch bei vielen Fernsehzuschauern Unmut
erzeugt hat damit ja es gibt ja auch
immer die andere Seite das ist das ist
alles ein bisschen
komplexer würde ich sagen wenn du wenn
du jemanden ich hatte vor einiger Zeit
war Tino krupala bei uns zu Gast oder
wenn du Alice Weidel einlädst oder auch
andere björn höcke ist noch mal eine
andere Geschichte weil björn höcke ist
tatsächlich jemand bei dem man sich
fragt ob der noch auf dem Boden des
Grundgesetzes steht und der erzählt das
auch in so einer in so einer Art und
Weise wirklich Wolf im Schafspelz dass
ich immer sagen würde da muss man
wirklich aufpassen und da haben wir auch
eine Verantwortung ne wir haben eine
Verantwortung für das was der erzählt
wird und es ist nicht immer so leicht
das zu dekodieren jemand wird Tino
krupala z.B mit dem habe ich genau
dieses Gespräch geführt und was ist das
für ein Deutschland wie wie würde ihr
Deutschland aussehen
und dann merkst du fängt an zu erzählen
aber es ist dann voller Widersprüche
dann gibt es auch diese seltsame
Sympathie für Putin und so weiter dann
macht man sich Gedanken um
Waffenlieferungen für die Ukraine und
dann merkst Du plötzlich okay das sehr
zu mehr so eine Wagenknecht Position
also so Hufeisen Theorie mäßig und und
du merkst da gibt es ganz ganz viele
Überschneidungen deswegen würde ich
niemals trotzdem sagen dass jemand wie
Sarah Wagenknecht ja jetzt plötzlich in
der AFD zu Hause ist und übrigens auch
nicht umgekehrt und ich finde das kann
man auch alles sagen was dann aber
passiert und das ist das wo ich die
Gefahr sehe du machst das und wenig
später taucht irgendwo im Netz der erste
Zusammenschnitt auf so macht Tino
propala Markus Lanz fertig
[Musik]
zur Hölle so war es doch gar nicht
sondern wir haben einfach versucht einen
vernünftiges Gespräch zu führen übrigens
auch ich habe nicht Tino Propeller
fertig gemacht auch das wäre eine
völlige Verkürzung dieses Gesprächs ich
erinnere mich mit mit gauland ein paar
man wirklich gute Gespräche und ich habe
ihm irgendwann mal ein Zitat vorgehalten
dass da lautet resortiment ist kein
Programm
das ist ein Satz von ihm selbst konnte
sich damals glaube ich nicht mehr so
richtig dran erinnern das war sehr
interessant und kein Programm sehr sehr
bezeichnender Satz genau und ich würde
auch sagen der Sündenbock ist kein
angemessenes Wappentier für
genau also immer nur zu wissen was an
den anderen doof ist richtig ersetzt
nicht eine eigene positive realistische
Pragmatik ja und programmatisch richtig
aber ich ich also ich sag mal so wir
sind mittlerweile in einer so
diversifizierten Medienlandschaft
unterwegs
egal was du machst du kannst es
hinterher durch geschicktes
zusammenschneiden dann wieder so drehen
dass es ganz ganz anders plötzlich
aussieht und ganz ganz anders wirkt das
nicht jeder jeder Medienjournalist ja
der nach deiner Talkshow nach anderen
Talkshows genauso
darüber schreibt und das kommt ja
häufiger vor ja in den etablierten
Leitmedien überregionalen Zeitungen und
so wer aus Sicht dieses Journalisten da
der große Sieger der Talkshow war und
wer was völlig absurdes behauptet hat
und so weiter das entscheidet dann in
diesem Moment der Journalist ja also er
deutet das aus und der der seine eigene
Meinung vertreten hat den findet er ganz
toll und das ist der große Sieger und
der der eine andere Meinung vertreten
hat ja völlig unmöglich und so weiter da
hast du in
etablierten seriösen Medien ganz ganz
starke Wertungen die manchmal auch bis
zur Karikatur verzerren was ich
tatsächlich in der Talkshow gespielt hat
naja hast du recht wenn man du erlebst
das ja auch manchmal ich erlebt das auch
manchmal damit habe ich kein Problem
wenn da wenn da jemand sitzt und und der
hat das so gesehen dann hat das so
gesehen ich sitze auch manchmal und frag
mich okay haben wir haben wir zwei
unterschiedliche Sendungen gleiche
Sendung gewesen haben ist richtig das
ist aber alles legitim und das ist auch
durch wenn er sagt das ist Kommentar und
das ist jetzt Meinung dann ist es durch
die Meinungsfreiheit absolut gedeckt sag
mal worüber ich mit dir noch reden würde
wir haben jetzt sozusagen die die
grundsätzliche Bedeutung des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks da sind
wir uns ja eigentlich und das Spannende
ist ja dass der öffentlich rechtliche
Rundfunk der wird häufig kritisiert und
nicht immer nur von Schwachmaten
diskutiert ja auch viel mit sich selbst
und
deswegen die entscheidende Frage was
meinst Du ja muss ich in den nächsten
Jahren vielleicht sogar Jahrzehnten
am System des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks verändern um im 21 Jahrhundert
auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise noch
seinen Platz zu haben die 2020
was natürlich eine große Frage das
einfach mal so so in zwei Sätzen zu
sagen das kriegt man glaube ich gar
nicht hin
also ich glaube erstmal ganz
grundsätzlich es gibt ernste Probleme
und es gibt Missstände und ich glaube
aber auch auf der anderen Seite
irgendwelche
massagestühle und vier Gänge Menüs sind
diese Probleme nicht ja das würde ich ja
sofort rausnehmen und würde sagen also
diese Dinge ja sind klassische
Management Probleme richtig eine und
klassische Kontrollproblem genau die
aber natürlich auf die genaue gleiche
Art und Weise in jeder anderen Firma
auftauchen können ist richtig nur dass
man beim öffentlich rechtlichen Rundfunk
da deutlich sensibler drauf guckt wenn
man am Ende Gebühren finanziert ist und
nicht von einem Unternehmen bezahlt wird
aber das Problem in der Sache ist ja
kein inhaltliches Problem und das
strukturelle Problem ist einfach
vielleicht dass der Missbrauch Spielraum
zu groß war das lässt sich aber relativ
schnell und einfach werden richtig genau
was willst du denn sagen Richard jetzt
mal aus deiner Sicht und dann sage ich
dir was ich darüber denke
kurz skizzieren also der eine ist die
Frage ist wer kontrolliert den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk das ist
ja jetzt im Falle hier ist ZDFs der
Fernsehrat wenn man sich anguckt wer
sitzt im Fernsehen Rad und warum dann
kann man ganz einfach da muss man nur
Fernseh Rad eingeben da sind alle
Mitglieder des Fernsehers drin die
Mitglieder des fernsehrads werden
bestellt von
Organisationen das ist in Rundfunk
Staatsvertrag oder wie auch immer das
heißt festgeschrieben wer das ist und
das müssen repräsentative Vertreter der
Gesellschaft sein also zum Beispiel
Vertreter der Gewerkschaft Vertreter der
Kirchen Vertreter von Sozialverbänden
Vertriebenen Verband ja stellt jemanden
in den Fernsehgarten so und wenn ich mir
angucke wäre da alles so sitzt und dann
denke ich mir ist das jetzt die
gesammelte Medienkompetenz
sind die Leute die da sitzen ja
diejenigen die genug Zeit in ihrem Leben
haben sich mit den Programmen so
intensiv zu beschäftigen dass sie
bestimmte Entwicklung die vielleicht
wenig gut sind auch tatsächlich
entdecken und sich damit auskennen und
du siehst natürlich dass das eine
rhetorische Frage ist weil ich das zwar
nicht für jeden der dort sitzt aber für
viele bezweifeln würde
und da denke ich mir das ist kein
ideales Kontrollgremium für die Zukunft
mehr
man müsste neu darüber nachdenken durch
wen und wer und auf welche Weise der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk
kontrolliert wird ich glaube ich habe
jetzt in Tutzing hat jemand den
Vorschlag gemacht die Mitglieder des
fernsehrad sollten vom Volk gewählt
werden da hätte ich gar nichts von die
kennt keiner das ist das erste Problem
und das zweite Problem ist an so einer
Wahl würde sich vermutlich niemand
beteiligen oder nur sehr sehr wenige
in der Schweiz gibt es eine Art Verein
der das ganze macht und da besteht
allerdings immer
unterwanderungsgefahr ne das also alle
Mitglieder der AFD ineinander eingehen
würden und zu sagen dieses diesen Verein
Kapern würden also sich da kluge
Gedanken zu machen wer sollte da rein
wie lange sollte der da rein da ich
glaube dieses System muss neu erfunden
werden das wäre ein Kritikpunkt
der jetzt unüberwindlich ist aber sie
nicht einfach
der zweite ist der Umgang mit
Selbstkritik also bei mir ist es so dass
ich in meinem freundes- und
Bekanntenkreis mein Vertrauen in
Menschen wächst in dem gleichen Maße wie
sie in der Lage sind
über sich selber zu lachen selbst
ironisch zu sein und Kritik zu
akzeptieren und ich finde das kann man
noch ein bisschen besser machen wir
haben ja mal so eine kleine Medien ganz
grundsätzlich besser machen nicht ja das
ist unsere Fähigkeit so Selbstkritik wir
haben unsere Kernkompetenzen wir messen
den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
nicht an den Maßstäben der privaten
Medien sondern wenn er so toll sein soll
wie wir ihn haben wollen dann müssen wir
deutlich sensiblere Spielregeln gelten
und da finde ich muss auch klarer sein
dass wenn man sagt ja dass man das
vielleicht einseitig oder dass man
bestimmte Dinge nicht oder was man nicht
gesehen hat oder wo man Fehler gemacht
hat das kommt mir insgesamt zu wenig vor
also ich finde dieses
ja also ich finde mehr Selbstkritik wäre
sehr vertrauen
das wären jetzt mal zwei Kritiken ja der
der Vorwurf der auch immer so kommt ist
also und einfach auf das Programm
schaust ne man fragt sich natürlich wie
passt das zusammen einerseits berichten
wir zurecht wie ich finde sehr kritisch
über eine Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in
Katar und auf der anderen Seite
übertragen wir sie dann also das heißt
auf der einen Seite kritisieren wir
super Beispiel ich habe mich hat das
genervt und aufgeregt wir haben dich
doch über die völlige Unmöglichkeiten
genau kamen unmittelbar vor Beginn der
WM die hätten zwei Jahre vorher laufen
müssen richtig du kannst dich erinnern
wir haben über Catan gemacht ja und ich
könnte sagen im übrigen bin ich der
Ansicht dass die WM dich in Katar
stattfinden soll aber was ist das denn
ja die ganze Zeit nichts zu sagen zu
einer Zeit als man die Dinge noch hätte
ändern können als der DFB noch hätte
sagen können wir fahren da nicht hin und
ich Bündnis genossen suchen und dass man
noch gegen die FIFA rebelliert hätte
nein als überhaupt nichts mehr zu machen
und zu ändern war da hat man dann so
proforma diese Kritik gemacht das wäre
mir natürlich viel lieber gewesen dass
eine ganze Welle dazu am besten nach der
Urteilsverkündung zugunsten von Katar im
Fernsehen gelaufen wäre das hätte in
viel viel bessere Funktion gehabt als
kurz vor der Weltmeisterschaft so sagt
ach übrigens finden wir das nicht gut
ist richtig ja worauf würdest du
verzichten Richard bei worauf könntest
du verzichten also würdest du Fußballfan
anders als Du ja aber ähm wenn ich mir
die irrsinnigen irrsinnigen Summen für
Übertragungsrechte
Fußballweltmeisterschaften und sowas
angucke und ich weiß auch jeder private
wäre dazu bereit diese Summen zu zahlen
dann überlege ich mir das eine Minute
eines Spiels Costa Rica gegen
Venezuela mehr kostet als ein Grimme
Preis ausgezeichneter Dokumentarfilm der
dem Zweifelsfall eine 100.000 Euro oder
so zur Verfügung jetzt interessant da
stimmen die Relationen nicht jetzt weiß
ich weil ich in meinem Leben ja mal
Medienjournalist war so Mitte der 90er
Jahre und dann weiß ich natürlich nicht
genau kritisiert Programmdirektor auch
das ja ich habe für die Zeit einiges
dazu geschrieben aber ich habe vor
einigen lange sales geschrieben über die
Zukunftsentwicklung des Fernsehens und
die digitalwirtschaft okay das war die
Zeit als man gerade so anfing über
digital das Wort war noch neu zu reden
ja jetzt weiß ich natürlich was sie
hinterlanden dazu sagen werden und die
sagen wenn wir das was alle interessiert
nicht mehr abdecken dann verlieren wir
die lagerfeuerfunktion dann sind wir
also nicht mehr das Programm und dass
ich alle versammeln und das heißt also
das geht auf kostenloser Quote und wenn
die Quote kleiner wird
auf das rechtfertigen der
Rundfunkgebühren noch schwieriger ist
richtig also wenn irgendwann nur noch
zehn Prozent ARD und ZDF gucken weil
dort manche Sachen nicht mehr laufen ja
also keine Schlagermusik mehr läuft und
kein Fußball mehr läuft und vielleicht
auch keine Skandinavien Krimis mehr
ausgestrahlt werden und das Ergebnis ist
am Ende dann dass die Quote in den
Keller geht dann können wir nicht mehr
rechtfertigen dass wenn 10% der
Bevölkerung ein Programm gucken dass sie
dafür gebührend sein müssen das ist die
Argumentation richtig aber auf der
Gegenseite führt es natürlich dazu dass
man irrsinniges Geld für den immer
teureren Fußball ausgeht denn auch in
überhaupt keiner Relation mehr dazu
steht dass jemand anderes das ja genauso
übertragen könnte und das ganze Geld
gespart würde um sehr hochwertiges
Fernsehen zu tun
da bin ich tendenziell eher auf der
Seite zu sagen keine
fußballübertragungsrechte in jedenfalls
nicht zu diesem Preis jetzt könnte ich
dagegen halten hier und das zeigt eben
wie differenziert der Blick dann darauf
sein muss wenn du dir ein heute journal
ja in der Halbzeitpause einer großen
Fußballübertragung anschaust hat
natürlich gigantische Quoten man könnte
immer sagen auch pass auf das führt dazu
dass Menschen plötzlich auch Nachrichten
gucken die sonst vielleicht nicht so tun
ja du könntest zum Beispiel auch sagen
na ja alle wir reden jetzt bei
Weltmeisterschaften von alle vier Jahren
ne also reden wir alle vier Jahre ich
konnte den anderen
ja anderes Beispiel anderes Beispiel
Sonntagabend gesetzt für viele Millionen
Menschen in diesem Land Tatort so und
danach kommt ein ein politisches
gesprächsformat Anne Will in dem Fall
früher was jemand anderer und so weiter
so das kommt dann direkt danach da wenn
wenn 13 Millionen Menschen Tatort gucken
dann ist natürlich so ein Grundrauschen
dem Grundmasse an Menschen da da werden
dann auch relevant viele Menschen die
politische gesprächsendung im Anschluss
gucken aber Markus ich will doch den
Tatort nicht abschaffen im Vergleich zu
vergleichbare Übertragungsrechten ja
also ja aber das ist ein Beispiel Tatort
ist ein schönes Beispiel mir mal mit
vergleichsweise wenig Geld sehr viele
Zuschauer binden kann richtig ja kann
man allerdings auch mit bestimmten
Formen von Spielshows und so weiter ist
mir schon richtig dass das geht aber
hier geht's um diese irrsinnigen
Beträgen die man sich ja kaum vorstellen
kann Schwindel erregend geworden sind
gegenüber früheren Zeiten und dieses
ganze Geld ne das stelle ich mir so
meinen Träumen vor würde ihn
qualitätsfernsehen investiert werden
also das würde mir sehr sehr gut
gefallen und da glaube ich wäre der
Nutzen deutlich höher als der Schaden
wenn man sich das noch mal anschaut
braucht es diese zwei Systeme 18,36 Euro
zahlt jeder Haushalt monatlich an
Rundfunkgebühren
vier Euro 69 also so eine halbe
Kinokarte ungefähr das ist das was das
ZDF davon bekommt und wir sind beide als
Menschen die fürs ZDF Arbeiten
interessiert mich vor allen Dingen das
ZDF du kriegst dafür für diese 4,69 €
kriegst du das ZDF Hauptprogramm kriegst
ZDFneo ZDF Info die Mediathek und so
weiter und Funk ja Content netzwerkfunk
gehört quasi auch dazu das kriegst du
jeden Tag 7 Tage die Woche 24 Stunden
lang für 4,69 €. ich finde das ist jetzt
kein schlechter Deal ich glaube der ist
deutlich weniger Moment
das zu teuer ist sondern das Argument
ist das ist nicht freiwillig ist
verstehe ich will nur trotzdem einmal
darauf hinweisen weil es
auch da muss man noch mal sagen was
kriegt man eigentlich dafür also die die
Geschichte oder das narrativ das dann
immer im Umlauf ist und nach dem Motto
was machen die eigentlich mit diesem
ganzen Geld und die hauen die Kohle zum
Fenster das haut so dann auch nicht hin
an dem Punkt aber jetzt sagt doch mal
ich meine ich habe mich jetzt zweimal
aus der Deckung geweint ja gewagt ja
einmal mit dem Fernseher Rad genau ich
denke dass das nicht mehr keine
zeitgemäße Form der Besetzung mehr ist
und das zweite Mal das muss ich überlegt
wie man Selbstkritik besser ins System
implementieren kann mich würde
interessieren was du denkst glaubst du
denn dass das so jetzt mal die
Einstiegsfrage glaubst du dass das jetzt
erstmal alles so genau so weitergeht wie
er das in den letzten Jahren und
Jahrzehnten gewesen ist oder glaubst du
das auch aus dem Inneren Diskussionen in
der Sender führt oder die Sender führen
zu größeren Veränderungen kommen wird
und welche würdest du dir wünschen also
da könnte man jetzt in ganz vieles
einsteigen ne und wir haben eben schon
gesagt Massage sitze und irgendwelche
bewirtungsbelege für Apfelstrudel das
ist nicht wirklich das Thema das ein
managementproblem so dass das zweite um
zum Rundfunk zurück ist natürlich die
Altersstruktur der Zuschauer wenn du dir
anschaust bei über 60-Jährigen ist ist
sozusagen die Bereitschaft die
Rundfunkgebühr zu bezahlen deutlich
ausgeprägter als bei jüngeren die zu
Recht auch sagen du pass auf ich ich
gucke das gar nicht ich finde mich da
überhaupt nicht wieder muss es trotzdem
bezahlen interessant ist dass viele
junge die zum Beispiel Funk
konsumieren wissen häufig gar nicht dass
das an öffentlich-rechtliches
Programmangebot ist oder
Deutschlandradio zum Beispiel da geht
diese Gebühr zum Teil auch rein wir
machen ganz großartigen Journalismus
also und dann geht's aber für mich und
da würde ich sagen das ist die
Aufgabe die wir vor allen Dingen haben
wo ist eigentlich in diesem
öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen
noch eine wirklich profilierte
konservative Stimme
was was ich meine du meinst auf der
Ebene von
von Inhalten Inhalten Inhalten wo sind
wirklich profilierte konservative
stimmen also denkst du jetzt so zurück
an die Zeiten vom ZDF Magazin und
Löwenthal oder so also sozusagen
berüchtigte konservative stimmen ja ich
gegeben hat oder oder
genau das war ja da hat man ja sozusagen
den Versuch gemacht beides abzubilden
aber wo ist heute im Fernsehen eine eine
wirklich profilierte konservative Stimme
ja also ich ich wenn ich jetzt am
konservativ denke ne dann fällt mir noch
ein hat nicht Heinz Klaus Mertes mal
fürs öffentlich-rechtliche gearbeitet
ich glaube schon und Sigmund gottliebt
eine konservativen Stimme ja ja das sind
also so Leute die mir jetzt einfallen ja
die gibt's nicht mehr okay
umgekehrt sagen dass es heute klar
profitierte linke Stimmen im rechtlichen
Fernsehen noch gibt ich werde nämlich
sagen es gibt beides weißt du was es ist
es gibt eine
also im Zweifel eher und das sagt man
mal drei Namen von Leuten im
öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen
arbeiten wo du sagen willst die nun
wirklich nicht also so Links hier so
links wie so links wie Klaus Betten Arzt
das war oder so ja also Leute die
wirklich dafür standen dass Sie links
waren also ich glaube da hat sich eine
Menge verändert also ich glaube ich
glaube das ist heute also ich denke mal
es gab eine Zeit wenn man sich die
späten 60er und die 70er anguckt ja wo
Journalisten sich sehr sehr klar und
deutlich politisch profiliert haben das
war allerdings auch eine Republik die in
rechts und links unterteilt war
ich habe ja schon häufig gesagt wir
haben heute eine große Koalition der
Mitte die 80% der Wählerstimmen abdeckt
ja und ich denke mal die allermeisten
Journalisten im öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk finden sich auch genau dort
wieder und ich jenseits davon das gilt
für links genauso wie für rechts oder
wenn du so willst links die früher ja
mal progressiv ist ja ein ausgestorbenes
Wort für konservativ ist übrig geblieben
ja aber ich meine ein bisschen mehr ein
bisschen mehr Kontur Wagen ja also so
ein Format wie Häuser Kinzel das war
oder so da spricht ja nichts gegen ja es
ist wobei das auch schon inszeniert war
ne es war schon Infotainment rechts und
links so aufeinander treffen zu lassen
ja es ist ist richtig ich habe weißt du
mein Thema ist es darf nicht der
Eindruck entstehen dass sozusagen die
sogenannten Eliten dass die alle unter
einer Decke stecken ja und dass sie sich
alle politisch im Grunde genommen einig
sind richtig und zwar die Journalisten
mit mit mit der Regierung und und und
sozusagen die die die
bürgerlichen ja die Grünen Wähler die
gut verdienenden grünen Wähler die die
dann irgendwo
in Berlin leben ja die die sind sich
alle einig und da entsteht so eine Front
sozusagen gegen die da draußen irgendwo
auf dem Land und so weiter ja Leute
Leute genau
Windräder doch echt eine feine Sache
sind ja nur dummerweise ist auch nichts
daran zu kriegen richtig und dummerweise
müssen sie dann aber diese Windräder
jeden Tag angucken und müssen aber auch
zusehen wie er ja ihre kleinen
Windräder gebaut werden keine Windräder
gebaut und die mobile die also entwertet
wird ist nicht die am Prenzlauer Berg
sondern die Immobilie die plötzlich
weniger wert ist weil sie im Schatten
von von fünf oder sechs gigantomanischen
Windrädern steht ist die der die auf dem
Land leben und nicht und hier und
offensichtlich wie willst du das im
System implementieren also
naja was ist
oder ja ich man kann das ja nicht
ansehen konkreter vorstellen also wenn
du wenn du sagst es gibt zu viel links
grünen Mainstream im Fernsehen wo ich
immer nicht weiß ob links doch das
richtige Wort ist der Vorwurf der häufig
kommen ich weiß genau
das gleiche ja ja ja
wobei ich eben sagen würde das links
heute nicht mehr grün nicht dasselbe
sind ja ich glaube es ist richtig die
die die konservativste Partei inzwischen
sind die Grünen also da kann man noch
lange noch mal einen schönen Podcast
drüber machen was ist links und rechts
heute aber das ist so ist das ist eine
eine Mitte
Mehrheitsgesellschaft gibt und das in
erster Linie diese Mitte
Mehrheitsgesellschaften meinungsmäßig im
öffentlich rechtlichen Rundfunk
repräsentiert ist ich glaube das würde
ich sofort sagen ja genau
sehr schwer haben ich würde sogar sagen
dass die ihm Journalismus ganz
grundsätzlich heute
ist gar nicht eine große Unterscheidung
zwischen öffentlich rechtlich und
private Verlagswirtschaft ja das würde
ich auch sagen ne aber der der und der
Punkt ist halt es wird zum Beispiel
interessant wenn du übers Gendern redest
ne
die die Leute regt es unfassbar auf wenn
wenn geändert wird jetzt bist du aber
stell dir vor du bist der Chefredakteur
oder die Chefredakteurin des ZDFs was
sagst du dann sagst du den Leuten die
vor der Kamera sind du musst Gendern
oder was du willst so exakt ja das
einzige sinnvolle Mann genau es gibt
richtig so wenn du das aber tust und
manche Kolleginnen Kollegen machen es
dann auch fängst du dir sofort den
Vorwurf ein dass du so eine gender bist
das wird dann so gesagt ja aber dann
haben die Leute nicht gut genug
hingeguckt weil der andere Recherche
macht ja auch die schöne Geschichte
kaputt so genau wie man das ja gar nicht
wissen ich will nur sagen es hat eine
enormes verhetzungspotenzial
in Tutzing gesagt hat weil der Satz die
eine Hälfte der Gesellschaft ertragen
dass die andere gendert und die andere
muss ertragen dass die andere Hälfte des
nicht tut
und das ist absolut auch meine Meinung
ist richtig ich denke
ich finde überhaupt dass jeder in dieser
Gesellschaft das Recht hat zu Gendern
und nicht zu Gendern und dass wir das
ertragen müssen und dass das Fernsehen
das genau so abbildet dadurch dass jeder
die Freiheit hat das so zu machen wie er
es für richtig hält ja es riecht aber
einmal klar das auszusprechen ist glaube
ich wichtig aber wenn jetzt zum Beispiel
dass das große Thema unserer Zeit
Klimaveränderung zum Beispiel ne würde
das anschaust es ist wahnsinnig
anstrengend z.B über das Thema dahinter
zu argumentieren zu sprechen zu sagen da
gibt's auch eine soziale Frage ja wenn
CO2 immer teurer wird wenn Energie immer
teurer wird dann haben Menschen mit
kleinen Gehältern ein echtes Problem und
wenn du das machst auch im Journalismus
und das meine ich wenn ich sage
profilierte konservative Stimme dann
wird das verdammt anstrengend dann wird
das ein sehr ungemütliches Wochenende da
musste sofort vorwerfen lassen dass du
so eine reaktionäre Flitzpiepe bis die
einfach nicht kapiert hat worum es jetzt
da draußen geht ja weil neben der
Menschheit ne diese Debatten
entsprechend offen auszutragen genau
tatsächlich wünschen ohne dass ich jetzt
wirklich immer an einem konkreten Format
davon Hause und kienslänge aber warum
nicht eine Befragung eines Politikers
wirklich von einem durchaus
konservativen Journalisten auf der einen
Seite und und von jemand der sich selbst
das Prädikat links noch zutraut auf der
anderen Seite also da finde ich sollte
man eher drüber nachdenken und man
sollte auch darüber nachdenken warum es
vielleicht schwierig ist im öffentlichen
öffentlich rechtlichen Rundfunk Karriere
zu machen wenn man sehr profilierte
politische Ansichten vertritt die nicht
immer genau in der Mitte sind
also das alles würde die Sache
vielleicht beleben dann wäre die mehr
der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk
wieder ein besseres Abbild der Breite
der Gesellschaft und nicht nur ein gutes
Abbild der Breite der Mitte ist richtig
und Helene Fischer darf dann trotzdem
weiter auftreten und Florian Silbereisen
auf dem Traumschiff unterwegs sein was
würde ich bin ich bin ich bin nicht der
Zensor der über die Geschmacksurteile
anderer Menschen diesbezüglich wacht ja
und deswegen
dieser schöne Satz dass die eine Hälfte
ertragen muss dass die andere das anders
sieht angehörig zu derjenigen Hälfte die
ertragen muss dass Florian Silbereisen
weiterhin wichtiger Bestandteil des
öffentlich rechtlichen Programms und ich
werde das gerne tun so genau und auch
wenn wir es vielleicht selber nicht
gucken sollten wir alles dafür geben
dass es trotzdem weiter darf
genauso ist das also Richard danke Dir
sehr
auf bald ja Tschüss
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]